foreign
hello everyone Mark Ellis here welcome
to RT Essentials so you just set up your
new 4K TV it's looking magnificent
mounted on the wall above your dusty old
DVD collection you can't wait to show up
your fancy new toy your friends are
chomping to the bit they said they're
gonna bring over snacks you got the time
you got the place pizza's on the way one
huge problem what are we gonna watch on
that thing let's remember not all movies
are made equally and with the cost of 4K
displays decreasing it means more
content is available in a higher
resolution so long 1080p you had a good
run but your 1920 horizontal pixels and
1080 vertical pixels they ain't cutting
it anymore especially since 4K has four
times that number of pixels and popular
streamers like Disney plus and Netflix
are constantly pumping out new releases
and ultra high definition even classic
films are getting a 4K restoration and
it's like seeing them again for the
first time are we just talking about
pixels today oh no we do get to
highlight movies they were beautiful
shot and perfectly showcase your new 4k
device a lot of hard work went into
giving you the ultimate in-home
experience and I think you'll agree it
was all worthwhile let's dig in in
glorious 4K Dunkirk
[Music]
foreign
things off with Dunkirk Christopher
Nolan's powerful depiction of the
real-life incident during World War II
in which 330
000 French British Belgian and Dutch
soldiers were safely evacuated from the
beaches of Dunkirk from the jump no one
intended for this film to be a visually
appealing film Penny one of his shortest
scripts to date which meant less
dialogue and more action and sparing no
expense to ensure that every detail was
as historically accurate as possible he
even insisted on filming at the actual
beaches in France where these events
took place despite the logistical
nightmare of doing so Nolan and
cinematographer Hoyt van hoytma shot on
65 millimeter large format film stock
and IMAX cameras
thank you
this is actually no one's first film to
be shot entirely on large format film a
decision that added many layers of
difficulty to an already challenging
production for starters IMAX cameras are
notoriously large heavy and loud and as
you can imagine it ain't something you
want to bring to the beach I know people
that won't even bring their cell phones
to the beach let alone a camera worth
half a million dollars no one also used
as many practical effects as possible
which meant employing thousands of
extras and finding period accurate ships
and planes there are also cardboard
cutout props of soldiers and vehicles so
that everything could be captured in
camera as opposed to relying on CGI
Nolan and his crew went to unprecedented
links to make this one of the most
visually stunning films of all time so
throw it up on your 4K TV you will not
be disappointed hey did I mention Harry
Styles is in it yeah he makes the film
look even better I'm just saying Blade
Runner 2049. don't you love me
foreign
[Music]
s were green
Jenny villeneuve's Blade Runner 2049
takes us to the year you guessed it 2049
where a new Blade Runner officer K
honors a long buried secret that has the
potential to punch what's left of
society into chaos as I'm sure most of
you are aware this film is the sequel to
the 1982 film Blade Runner directed by
Ridley Scott which was also wanted for
its visuals so as you can imagine
there's a lot of anticipation leading up
to the sequel 35 years in the making to
make this movie as visually impressive
as possible Villeneuve teamed up with
legendary cinematographer sir Roger
Deacon whose work includes the Shawshank
Redemption Skyfall 1917 and two other
villain new films prisoners and sicario
for 2049 deacons insisted on using a
single camera setup shooting in 1.55 to
1 aspect ratio from one re Alexa XT
Studio camera assisted by dollies and
crane arms all right
stay back
for all of you unfamiliar with aspect
ratios it basically refers to the ratio
of an image's width to its height in
other words the size of the image not
something most people would think about
but it ends up making a huge difference
in how a film is perceived unlike
Dunkirk Villa news 2049 relied heavily
on visual effects so he hired the
creative Studio frame store to create
the large-scale environment builds and
Moody atmospheres and wetted digital to
create many of the Practical Miniatures
and sets combining these elements with
deacons of cinematic lighting expertise
created a visual experience unlike any
sci-fi movie ever seen the film even won
best cinematography and best visual
effects at the 90th Academy Awards Star
Trek Into Darkness Spock Nobody Knows
the rules better than you but there has
got to be an exception none such action
violates the prime directive shut up
Spock we're trying to save you Doctor
the needs of the many outweigh the needs
of the few we're talking about your
life the rule cannot be problems
try to get them back online 90 seconds
to detonations
[Music]
Spock over here and over there what
would he do the second installment in
the rebooted Star Trek film series is
Star Trek Into Darkness directed by JJ
Abrams with cinematography by Dan Mendel
it follows Captain Kirk and the crew of
the Enterprise who are on a mission to
the Klingon Homeworld seeking to capture
a one-man weapon of mass destruction
former Starfleet member John Harrison is
that his real name an epic space mission
requires an epic approach to filmmaking
so what I'm saying is this crew had to
boldly go where no filmmakers had ever
gone before yeah I went there Abrams and
Mendel shared an affection for the
anamorphic format which means shooting a
widescreen picture on standard
millimeter film with a non-wide screen
native aspect ratio since the image is
squeezed horizontally it creates a
trademark oval bokeh and a shower depth
of field plus that horizontal lens flare
it's just so magical Mendel reached out
to Wally Fister who had worked with
Nolan on The Dark Knight films to
discuss his experiences shooting
anamorphic combined with IMAX
the beach is that way right now we're
not going to the beach
I hate that I know you do
naturally Fister and no one started
lobbying for Abrams to shoot in a
similar manner for Into Darkness which
he did Abrams and Mendel shot 35
millimeter for all interior scenes and
65 millimeter for the exteriors so that
the transitions wouldn't be as
distracting the 65 millimeter material
was shot using four IMAX cameras with a
combination of lenses some of which were
alone to the production by no one
himself and who better than industrial
Light and Magic to provide more than 700
of the film's effect shots including the
rendering of the Enterprise which you
know you can't screw up unless of course
you want millions of trekkies swearing
at you in Klingon all over Reddit ilm
also rendered the interior and exterior
shots of the volcanic planet Nibiru
which were straight fire
sorry but it was unsurprisingly Into
Darkness was nominated for best visual
effects at the 86th Academy Awards
the Revenant
2015's the Revenant was co-written and
directed by Alejandro Gonzalez inoritu
with cinematography by Emmanuel lubesky
AKA chivo the duet recently won Oscars
for their work on Birdman and they'd
each win again for their Revenant
actually Chiva won the best
cinematographer for Oscar three years in
a row you see gravity came out the year
before Birdman the guy's good for the
Revenant Alejandro and chivo utilized a
similar shooting style as Birdman
carefully rehearsing and choreographing
each scene to tell a story with as few
Cuts as possible Alejandro lied on a
single camera with no Dolly his
signature move this allowed the director
to get extremely close to the actors in
action and the audience as a result
feels more connected to what we're
seeing though the filmmakers originally
intended to shoot on film the harsh
weather conditions proved to be too much
for such sensitive equipment so they
switched everything over to digital
it
died
[Music]
Alejandro and chevo used telescoping
cranes a Steadicam and handheld cameras
specifically an Alexa M and an Alexa XT
according to chibo they used very wide
lenses which allowed them to show all
the contacts of the environment at the
same times as showing the emotion and
being able to be closer to the actors so
in his words the relationship between
the environment and the actors is always
present and speaking of environment this
film was shot in the remote wildernesses
of Canada and Argentina where the crew
captured some of the most beautiful
landscapes and backdrops imaginable but
such beauty came at a price as the crew
and cast had endured harsh conditions
like freezing temperatures and icy
Rivers additionally much of the gear had
to be transported on sleds and
snowmobiles or hiked in and poor
DiCaprio had to fight a bear you seen
the movie scary it did win him his first
Oscar for best actor so I would say
that's somewhat bearable I couldn't help
my myself Lawrence of Arabia is dead
yes
why
this is my well
I have drunk from it
you are welcome many of the directors
and cinematographers on this list took
inspiration from David Wayne's classic
Lawrence of Arabia the Epic tale of T.E
Lars and his experiences in Arabia
during the first world war this being
the oldest film on our list I don't
really have to explain that CGI wasn't
exactly possible back then and there
weren't even a fraction of the camera
and lens options available today so lean
and sigmatographer Freddie young
deserved that much more credit for
creating what is widely regarded one of
the best films ever made for the desert
scenes the crew shot in Jordan Morocco
and Spain with most of the other
exteriors and the Interiors also being
shot in various regions of Spain only
two kinds of pre-check and fun of the
desert veterans and gods and John
neither
take it from me for ordinary man it's a
burning fiery furnace
no dragon
it's going to be fun
it is recognized that you have a funny
sense of fun
instead of anamorphic lenses super
Panavision technology was used for the
shooting which meant 70 millimeter
spherical Optics we never shot coverage
and took time carefully composing each
sequence so that he needed as few takes
as possible this is also a cost
efficient method and helped lighten the
load for the guys sweeping down the
camel tracks in the Blazing desert deep
after every take that's a true story
parts of Arabia had undergone several
Restorations including a director's cut
that was supervised by lean and released
in 1989 an 8K scan slash 4k digital
restoration was completed for Blu-ray
and Theatrical re-release by Sony
pictures but the film's 50th Anniversary
I suggest that you pick that up this is
Steven Spielberg's favorite movie of all
time and that guy seems to know a thing
or two about movie making
2001 A Space Odyssey
[Music]
next up one of the most influential
sci-fi films ever made 2001 A Space
Odyssey directed by Stanley Kubrick with
cinematography by Jeffrey unborn unlike
many of the other films on this list
Kubrick shot almost entirely on sound
stages for obvious reasons it's kind of
difficult to shoot on location in outer
space I guess it's only a matter of time
before that becomes the norm though the
studios were located in England and
Kubrick used the same super Panavision
70 millimeter Optics that were used in
Lawrence of Arabia and the color
processing was done using the
Technicolor dye transfer process which
had undergone improved versions since it
became popular during the Golden Age of
Hollywood it's important to note that
this film came out almost a full decade
before Star Wars yet it still visually
holds up a major reason for that was
Kubrick's insistence that all of the
special effects shots were captured in
camera which meant avoiding blue screens
and traveling mats this in-camera
technique was extremely painstaking much
like how Nolan crafted his sequences in
Dunkirk I've still got the greatest
enthusiasm and confidence in the mission
and I want to help you
Dave
stop
will you
stop Dave the crew had to build these
large models like the discovery one
spacecraft which stretched 55 feet
across additionally Kubrick spent 750
thousand dollars to construct a giant
rotating wheel that could house the sets
which gave viewers the illusion that the
ship was spinning but it wasn't all an
illusion after all these are only a
fraction of the techniques that Kubrick
pioneered many of which would become the
industry's standard for the film's 50th
Anniversary new 70 millimeter prints
were struck from the original film
negatives and restored a process that
was carried out under the supervision of
guess who Christopher Nolan
Spider-Man into the spider-verse what
did you say your name was Dr Olivia
Octavius
[Music]
can I assume that your friends call you
DACA my friends actually call me Liv
my enemies call me.com
Spider-Man into the spider-verse hey
just because it's animated doesn't mean
it isn't 4K TV worthy the visual effects
team at Sony Pictures imageworks was
tasked with making this film look and
feel like a vintage comic book and
specifically pay homage to the work of
Sarah pacelli who created the iconic
protagonist Miles Morales AKA Spider-Man
it's not the Peter Parker one this is my
favorite Spider-Man movie of all time
what started as one animator working
with the directors to establish the
film's look then expanded to six the
animators then 142 and then at
1.177 making this the largest animation
crew that image Works had ever used for
a film
my room
why is this happening
please stop sticking
[Music]
please keep wait wait
how could there be two Spider-Man there
can't be two Spider-Man
[Music]
the directors wanted each frame to look
like a painting when paused staying true
to the comic book style so the animators
had to come up with clever ways to do so
like taking rendered CGI frames and
working on top of them in 2D
additionally colors were deliberately
misaligned as if they had been slightly
misprinted which is common in the ink
printing of real Comics it took a team
of Highly skilled superheroes to bring
into the spider-verse to life but it
paid off because it was a box office
Smash and one best animated feature at
The 91st Academy Awards Mad Max Fury
Road
[Music]
[Applause]
director George Miller and
cinematographer John seal teamed up for
the post-apocalyptic reboot Mad Max Fury
Road this film is non-stop action from
start to finish you barely have time to
reach for your popcorn or check your
Tick Tock since now you're watching this
at home
please don't do that seal who had worked
on the legendary films The English
Patient and The Perfect Storm actually
came out of retirement to do Fury Road
him and his crew decided to shoot
digitally on several re-o exit cameras
his first time not shooting on film
which he felt was appropriate given the
harsh working condition you know the
sandstorms the extreme heat all that fun
desert stuff
they shot on location in Namibia with
most filming taking place in the dorob
National Park known for its arid desert
Plains it did make for a beautiful
setting and it allowed plenty of space
for the crew to build out their Rigs and
achieve a reported 90 percent of the
effects practically also the more than
150 stunt performers some from Cirque du
Soleil needed room to you know do their
thing though most of the effects in
stunts were achieved practically the
film still required 2 000 visual effects
shots which included weather altering
effects and terrain replacement so sure
Mad Max Fury Road will show off your
TV's 4K definition but it's also great
inspiration for your next Burning Man
outfit star war is the Last Jedi
yes
a sacred Island watch the language
[Music]
old friend
I wish I could make you understand
but I'm not coming back
nothing can make me change my mind Star
Wars The Last Jedi was written and
directed by Ryan Johnson with
cinematography by his go-to right-hand
Man Steve yetlin despite what filmmakers
like Christopher Nolan and Quentin
Tarantino believe Yedlin disagrees that
film is better than digital and uses the
Last Jedi as the ultimate proof that
there are other factors that go into
achieving a film or digital look aside
from the camera itself that's because
the Last Jedi was roughly 50 digital and
50 film with the footage mixed in every
which way the shots were cut together
seamlessly and even yeppelin had trouble
knowing which one was which in
post-production I failed you Ben
I'm sorry I'm sure you are
the resistance is dead the war is over
and when I kill you
I will have killed The Last Jedi
125 sets were created on 14 sound stages
at Pinewood Studios in England and this
film used more practical effects than
any other Star Wars feature to date with
roughly 200 creatures created including
a puppet Yoda like in The Empire Strikes
Back additionally yetland used re Sky
Panel LED lights throughout the course
of the shoot often in large arrays where
they were able to change the colors and
even play scenes mathematically
beautiful lighting stunning locations
across England Ireland Croatia and
Bolivia and Yoda crafted like the good
old days of Empire Strikes Back you
gotta see this one in 4k The Matrix how
about
I give you the finger
and you give me my phone call
no Miss
you disappoint me you can't scare me
with this gestapo crap I know my rights
I want my phone calls last but certainly
not least is the Matrix written and
directed by the wachowskis with
cinematography by Bill Pope this one
changed it all the premise the
characters their clothing choices the
groundbreaking wire work and
choreography visual effects that were so
Innovative they make me question whether
we're all just living in some sort of
simulation but the one thing that stands
out about this film the most is the
overall look that extreme stylization
the green Hues the stark contrast of the
bluish real world the Dark comic book
feel that looms throughout the whole
movie it all leaves a lasting impression
even without the technical Feats and
those are plenty as well I mean I could
spend an entire episode just describing
how bullet time was created I'm gonna
enjoy watching you die
Mr Anderson
I could spend another episode just
diving into the three-minute lobby
shootout scene which took 10 days to
film and was achieved without CGI almost
all scenes were filmed at Fox Studios in
Sydney and were shot on film using super
2.39 to 1 aspect ratio for the film's
20th anniversary the original camera
negatives were pulled from The Vault and
scanned in 4k with HDR Dolby contrast
and color toning supervised by Bill Pope
himself if you haven't seen that version
I suggest you get to it but hey I can
only show you what you want to watch
you're the one that has to hit the
button and that concludes our list of
the most visually stunning movies for 4K
TVs of course there's plenty of titles
that deserve to be here but we're all
out of time don't worry we got tons of
new episodes of RT Essentials coming
your way I'm sure we'll get there soon
thanks for tuning in I'm Mark Ellis and
to all you aspiring filmmakers out there
remember what Yoda said the greatest
teacher failure is
[Applause]
[Music]